bill Rabinowitz has been covering this
story Ohio State football beat writer
for Columbus Dispatch he joins us now
bill how are you today good how are you
I'm okay I was wondering and I've been
wondering a couple things with Urban
Meyer if this was earlier in the summer
and not closer to the football city was
there any chance Urban Meyer was not
going to be back that's a good question
we at the press conference we did not
have the full report at the time all we
had was a three page summary so
reporters there including myself could
not ask questions based on the actual
findings because we didn't have that yet
so so some of our questions had to be
more general because we didn't have
specifics to ask about that's what and
they've not made those people available
president Drake for example and I've
requested that so we don't know we are
kind of flying half blind a little bit
in that press conference I I do get the
sense that president Drake wanted
stiffer penalties and some members of
the board did and I think this was a
compromise
how much president Drake wanted I don't
know we are trying to find that out but
I I it was clearly there was some
tension and friction in the room because
that meeting that most people thought
would be a few hours lasted 10 or 12 it
was a very very long - finish the
sentence Urban Meyer is still Ohio
State's head coach because well first of
all he's very good at his job and
secondly I do not believe they felt that
the mistakes that he made were fireable
offenses or they didn't want to fire him
over those what do you still want to
know there are a lot of things I'd like
to know based on the report why did
Orban Meyer have his texts deleted or
his phone reprogrammed so that they
deleted texts automatically after one
year I would like to know whether Shelly
Meyer told Urban Meyer about the
allegations and most of all honestly
I'd like to know the truth about whether
there was domestic violence so we don't
know that Zach Smith was not charged we
don't know why it was a palpable
Department has not been forthcoming
about why if they did not charge him it
may have been because they didn't
believe the accusations and may have
been some other reason we don't know
there's still this long into the story
there's still more things we don't know
then do know which is which is
frustrating is this story over no it's
not over it may never be over it's not
going to be over until Urban Meyer
returns is that could be over until
Urban Meyer adjusts back to the program
he's been divorced from for now a month
roughly and in terms of Urban Meyer's
legacy and reputation and all that it
may never be over
some of it depends on what happens from
here how much we find out about the
veracity of the domestic violence
accusations which will color Ohio
State's response to them no this story
is far from over
unfortunately I've mentioned this a
couple of times this morning bill
I think urban did not say anything about
Courtney Smith because in his mind no
just my opinion as I'm watching him say
this I I don't know if he believes that
there was any domestic violence maybe it
was just a bad marriage but that was my
feeling it was after the fact because he
was given ample opportunities to say
something about her and then waited till
Friday because I felt like there was
some inside pressure to say well you
know how bad this looks it looks like
you're so insensitive here and then
that's when he came out with the hey you
know I'm sorry
you know what Courtney Smith went
through what do you make Wednesday to
Friday yes I think you might be right I
think one other factor that should be
mentioned is that everybody on that
podium on Wednesday was absolutely
physically and mentally and probably
emotionally exhausted as I said it was a
much longer day than most people thought
it probably wasn't a good idea to have
the press conference then anyway
especially not giving the media the full
report so there were a lot of you know
it was very kind of a strange press
conference in that way and I do think
there's something - I think there are
real questions about what you said and
and I don't think that Norbert Mayer is
he is not going to say something that he
doesn't believe yeah and
and you know I again the thing is only
two people really know what happened
between Zach and Courtney in that Zach
and Courtney and maybe the power police
department but we don't know what they
really think so there's so much gray
area here and I just think you know and
I'm sure blue mire was very upset and
very you know embarrassed to have been
suspended he's the guy who's never had
NC double-a issues he's never been
suspended and nothing like this yeah
there were there was a lot of criticism
of some of the stuff that happen in
Florida with some of the player arrests
and things like that but but you know
this was kind of a whole new ball game
and I think he's deeply hurt by it you
mentioned this in a column the NCAA and
that aspect of this that the a you know
do you think the NCAA gets involved in
in the Ohio State situation it's a
possibility I don't think that's a major
major potential story but it's something
they might look at the issue I think the
biggest issue is when Zach Smith and
another Ohio State coach was nameless in
the in the report went to a strip club
and apparently took a high school coach
or two alongside if that if they paid
for the coach if there were you know
stuff that happened there that could be
a impermissible benefit obviously the
bad look to go to the strip club anyway
but in terms of the n-c-double-a stuff
it could be an issue as if they gave any
kind of benefit to those coaches bill
good stuff and we'll keep reading thank
you thank you Dan let's build
rabinowitch he covers the Buckeyes
Columbus Dispatch yeah I think the
n-c-double-a part of this is what's
interesting and if you really want to
get those text messages you can get
those text messages how badly do you
want to and I don't think there's gonna
be full transparency here and even if
there is are we gonna know if there's
full transparency but it's there there
without him for the first three weeks
usually pretty easy what do you have
Oregon State Rutgers then TCU okay
TCU okay but that's about it
for more Dan Patrick show too
channel 239 on Direct TV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]